hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to my game engine series
been a while since the last episode we
had the whole optimization october thing
so we took a little bit of a break from
the series october has now finished
optimization october has only just begun
but nevertheless we're going to return
to the kind of weekly game engine series
episodes i suspect that there's probably
going to be a few over the course of the
next week or two so more than usual just
because there are a lot of minor things
that we have to do and they're pretty
easy and i just want to kind of you know
get into it so let's take a look at
where we kind of left off um the last
thing that i believe we did was
basically implementing this whole
physics situation with box 2d being able
to hit play and then seeing our
game kind of thing work so this is
pretty exciting because we now have like
box duty physics working and we now have
this kind of game world that we can
design hit play and then simulate which
is which is great i mean it's a step
into the right direction in terms of
what we need to actually make a game
engine capable of producing games now if
we take a look at the road map
and what we're going to be doing today
um this kind of uh this is by the way
this roadmap is the roadmap of what we
are doing in this kind of game engine
series here on youtube but it's also
like the road map of what we're doing on
the live stream so for those of you who
don't know every like thursday morning
afternoon australian time
i
live stream on twitch.tv slash the
journal my twitch channel and
i do specifically game engine series
stuff so last thursday we resumed the
streams because optimization october or
at least october has finished so you can
always check back there because the vods
stay up for 60 days after which i
usually upload them to patreon for
patreons so you can actually check and
check out the whole backlog if you're a
patron but nevertheless if you check out
that live stream that's a good example
of where we're heading and in fact i
think that a lot of the work that we're
going to be doing over the next few
episodes has been done in the previous
live stream or even live stream before
that
anyway point being that this road map
may in fact say that for example circle
colliders have been implemented but
realistically they haven't actually been
implemented in the game engine series
yet they've been implemented uh
during the live streams if that makes
sense and i think if you go to
the official github page for this game
engine series repository for hazel 2d
which is github.com
hazel real hazel is actually on gitlab
so it's entirely separated from this but
there's a dev branch and this dev branch
um you can see like has circles and
stuff
so this is stuff i must not have pushed
the latest code from the live stream but
anyway um so if you want to keep up to
date with like stuff that's basically
marked as completed here in the roadmap
definitely make sure that you check out
the dev branch because we are currently
on the physics branch and that is in
sync with these videos so just a little
bit of like housekeeping and a little
bit of like explanation as to what is
going on where everything is because i
know it's been a while and if you're
kind of keeping up with this series um
you kind of need to get into this i'm
actually working on a website as well so
that will explain this so that i don't
have to say it like maybe in in every
video or whatever could have added it to
the readme but anyway point is um soon
i'll have something to link to that will
explain like the workflow and how
everything is working so what are we
doing today
well
circle colliders would be fantastic to
have
but the thing is
we need to be able to render circles
because if we don't have a
a way to actually render a circle then
how can we make a circle collider well
of course we could simply render a quad
with a texture applied to it because we
know that we can you know choose to
texture these quads if we go to textures
and drag in like the cherno logo there
we go we now have
the turner logo and that is you can see
vaguely almost looks like a circle
rather than a square because it's got a
lot of transparency in it so we couldn't
we could in fact just drag on like a
circle texture right so something that
we've made in like photoshop or paint or
whatever where like the edges are kind
of transparent not the edges but you
guys know what i mean like literally
drawing a circle and making like the the
outer sides just transparent
and then we could actually like add a
circle collider to it but i think it
would be a lot better if we had the
ability to actually render circles uh
because this is something that is just
useful to have in general but also we're
definitely going to be we're definitely
going to need some way of rendering
circles so that when we have a circle
collider we can actually visualize it if
you look back at this road map one of
the things that we have to do is
visualize colliders and that's actually
done on the the latest live stream that
we had so we need to be able to like
show these the bounds of this box
collider because of course we can offset
it we can resize it and also for
debugging the actual engine development
to make sure that this is in fact the
right size we can't see it we can kind
of validate that by just looking and
being like yeah that looks vaguely right
but it's a lot better to be able to
visualize those colliders
and that's something we need to work
towards now to give you guys a little
bit of a better idea of what we're
actually working on i thought i would
open up the real hazel this is the hazel
version that you can get on patreon if
you support on patreon patreon.com
you guys know all that stuff um which
also helps to support this series by the
way so it's it's worth doing anyway
plugging aside um
what you can do here is if you come into
like the settings then we have this like
show physics colliders thing and this
works for both like 2d and 3d colliders
so
in this case we mostly have 3d colliders
because this is in fact a 3d game world
however if i go ahead and create like
um you know some kind of let's just make
an empty entity
let's go to it and then if i add a
2d collider to it which is what we can
do in hazel 2d as well a box collider 2d
you can see that we can we can see it
let me just maybe drag it up a little
bit you can see that it isn't it's a
different color just so that we can
differentiate it from 3d colliders so 3d
colors are green because physx
2d colliders i thought i'd make them
blue
and if we have like a circle collider on
it which i think we can add both you can
see that shows up as a circle not sure
why the default radius is one but uh you
can see that we we can actually show it
up we can visualize it as a circle now
this circle is a bit different than like
the circles i talked about in my recent
circles video which i'll get to in a
minute because you can see it's actually
made out of line segments this is just
something we use for debug rendering
it's just drawing lines same as this
actual square but the point is you can
see we can kind of visualize this
collider
and it's a 2d collider by just
toggling on this kind of
show physics colliders and there's even
an on top setting where if i just turn
that on then it will actually show
everything like without depth testing so
that's useful if you have some collider
you know far away and you want to be
able to see everything kind of through
everything well not necessarily far away
but if you have like a complex scene
maybe you just want to see the colliders
and you don't really care about like
walls obscuring them and stuff like that
but anyway point being this this is what
i'm talking about when i talk about
visualizing colliders it's just it's
useful so that we can actually both
debug our engine as we're developing it
then also when we're working on a game
maybe we want to make a collider that's
like slightly bigger than we need for
whatever reason and
we can easily just make sure that it is
in fact the right size by doing
something like this now also when we
have more complicated colliders in the
future this is going to be absolutely
necessary so with box 2d we have the
ability to actually uh produce fairly
complicated like physics things right so
we can chain like joints together we can
also make arbitrary polygon colliders
and i plan on supporting that in hazel
2d because it's quite cool and it's
quite useful and so in that case what we
would do and what we would give the user
the ability to do is actually like place
a bunch of like points around in like 2d
space i guess
within our 3d world somewhere and then
we could actually kind of use that to
draw out a polygon and that obviously is
really going to need to be visualized in
some way because it really is arbitrary
there's another way to see it right it's
not something that we ultimately render
it's just something that the physics
system will will have and these these
kind of
visualizations i guess right these
visualizers are a way for us to actually
visualize the mathematical data that is
then going to be used by the physics
system anyway i think that you guys get
the point of like visualizing these
colliders i don't know why i went into
so much detail explaining it all
but let's dive in and take a look at
circles today because that's really kind
of what i wanted to do today um i spent
a lot of time talking about colliders
because that's what we're going to use
circles for in part but also how do we
render circles well i made a video
recently literally called how to render
circles um this is me this is this is a
circle um
the video is like pretty good i think
it's about 40 minutes long it goes into
depth it doesn't actually feature like
an engine implementation that's what
we're going to do today so this is going
to be useful but ultimately if you go to
this shader toy example here in the
description then this is like the circle
that we can render and we can have it
filled in we can have it not filled in
here is the shader code for how to
render a circle if you guys don't know
what i'm talking about why is there
shader code how do we render how do we
render a nice smooth soft circle
definitely check out this video i'll
have it linked and it'll be in the
description as well um because this is
going to teach you how
to actually render this why it works how
it works all of that stuff and why we
want to do it this way but today i'm
just going to be able to take the code
and just not explain it that much
because it's been explained in this
video so definitely check out this video
um if you haven't already seen it so how
do we go about integrating this into our
engine well the thing is since it is an
engine
since we are making an engine um and we
want to integrate this kind of circle
rendering into our game engine we need
to think about like how one would use
this
so
it's not just about like let's write a
function called render circle take in
some parameters and we're done that's
great if you're building some kind of
library or framework that's how it works
but because this is a game engine
there's a there's an entirely like
uh
separate level of complexity to it which
is like
how do i actually set up this game world
to render a circle if i if that's what i
want to do if i want to make this square
a circle how do i interact with it here
now what you can do and what i actually
ended up doing i think in the live
streams um where i
integrated circles into like the dev
branch of hazel 2d so on twitch or that
all the stuff that i was doing is i
ended up making like another component
called a circle renderer right so a
sprite renderer is specifically made for
rendering like a rectangle that is the
that is the geometry there now in the
future we may want to
create some kind of 2d mesh
like a like a polygonal shape i guess
that
would wrap around a texture if it had a
lot of transparency in it
that's something that we may want to
explore in the future it's a bit of a
minor optimization if you ask me so i
don't think we'll be doing it anytime
soon but for now the way that we define
sprites is they are a quad in the
rendering pipeline in the game engine
they are a quart they are a rectangle
right now they don't have to be uniform
we can scale these however we like right
and they're going to be totally fine so
they don't have to be
like an exact square or anything but
they have four edges it's like a polygon
with four edges that is what a sprite is
it can be textured it can be not
textured and that's
like whatever right you can just drag a
texture in and it's now textured that
doesn't matter point being oh we have no
way to get rid of this texture that's
nice we can tint the texture as well
which is nice but the point is they are
that that's what they are geometrically
they are just a quad and they expect to
maybe have a texture or a color and
that's it now a circle geometrically is
also going to be a quad because of how
we render it however the appearance of
it will always be a circle and
furthermore we know that to render
circles using our desired approach we
need to obviously run it on a shader
so we need to somehow have a pipeline
now for rendering circles i could like
somehow put it into sprite renderer but
in my opinion i think that it would be
just easier if there was a circle
renderer component instead and then you
can you know have your circle related
parameters here and furthermore you
won't be able to texture it why because
there's no sense in texturing a circle
if you want a textured circle make the
texture be a circle and apply it to a
sprite renderer right because the
geometry at the end is going to be
identical they're both being rendered on
quads but one has this kind of shader
that can render color and tint and
tiling and textures and the other one is
going to be able to render circles of
varying softnesses and maybe with like
like doughnuts and you know
discs circles whatever all of that
related stuff
okay so that is basically my explanation
let's dive in and implement this uh i'll
put like i always
i'm to try and always put chapters
throughout these videos just to
so that people can skip to the past that
they actually want to see because i know
that these are usually just a bunch of
information and not everyone wants to
sit through it
but let's dive in and take a look at how
we can implement this so step one is
going to be to take a look at our actual
renderer
now what i'm actually going to do is
probably something a little bit
different so in this video i don't have
any reference code i'm going to
implement it just using that shader code
that i showed you i'm going to pretend
to be you watching this video and being
like how do i implement this in my game
engine i think that'll probably produce
the most value hopefully to you people
but uh
we're also since we are integrating this
into a game engine and not necessarily
just like a framework or something we
are going to think about the user kind
of uh user interface and all that so we
have to make a circle component and i'm
actually going to start from that
so if we go into components um we have
all of our components here all right
um now what i want to do is we have this
like box collider component rigid body
component we've got all this stuff now
what i want to do and actually let me
quickly take a look at i don't think i
ended up doing
this i just want to familiarize myself
with this code quickly um
yes we have all these all on component
added we copy component if exist okay
yeah cool so we didn't get around to
doing the list of components yet we'll
do that at some point um but anyway so
we have a sprite renderer component
let's just copy this component
and i'm going to call it a circle
renderer component now we have color no
texture and we should have some kind of
radius now we're going to start this off
with 0.5 why because everything by
default is one meter in hazel so in
other words when you pre when you create
like a
you know a when you add a sprite render
component to a um to an entity then it
will appear as like a one by one meter
quad in this case we want a one meter
diameter circle so radius of course is
half the diameter so we can make the
radius 0.5 by default and that should be
good
uh by default i mean if
i don't think we need like constructions
like this mostly just a default
constructor copy constructor is good
because we have this here and it will be
white by default now there are
definitely other things we want to
control um there's a parameter that's
going to be called thickness now if it's
a one and this is you can refer to the
actual shader to see what these
parameters should be if the thickness is
one it's 0.5 here but if we change the
thickness to one this is what it looks
like it's a filled in circle right and
if we make the thickness like point one
it will be a lot thinner now this is
somewhat resolution dependent i'm not
sure if we'll stick with this we might
be able to use like shader uh
derivatives and stuff like that to make
this a little bit better we might look
at that look into that in the future
i want to obviously implement this in a
simple way so that it's easy to
understand and also gets the job done
for the majority of people uh but we
yeah with the thickness we'll probably
just leave it like this where one is a
filled in circle
and then something like point five is
like half filled in or whatever and then
we also have fade so this can be used
for like stylistic effects if you want a
circle like that
you know why not give people the ability
to kind of do that right i think that's
probably
worth doing
um so fade and thickness are really the
two parameters we expose of course color
as well but we've already kind of talked
about color because color is up here
okay so um that being said let's add in
that fade now by default i guess we'll
keep this at like point zero zero five
immediately it's kind of occurring to me
that these are very weird numbers right
like a fade of 0.005 like what does that
even mean so i'm not sure if we'll keep
them like this because we have to think
about what this is like to the user
now again a thickness zero to one i
guess that makes sense one is like the
completely filled in
0.01 might be like a thin outline but
fade you know like realistically again
0.005 is a nice number but like i don't
really imagine people will be like oh
yeah let's make it .05 or whatever so
i'm not sure like what this should be
uh for now we'll just leave it like this
and i will leave it exposed just in case
people want like ultra blurry or
whatever circles for whatever effect
they're going for but
yeah just like a note that we may have
to revisit this because i don't see this
being very user-friendly
okay so now that we have that how do we
integrate it with the rest of our engine
well we have to make uh well that's kind
of really it as far as like declaring
the component but we have to add some ui
for it and that's what this is for in
the scene hierarchy panel so circle
renderer component
circle renderer
so color we don't need any textures so
we'll have color
this will be like the thickness
so the thickness is going to be
component.thickness
and uh we have like a a speed and then a
minimax so speed i might make like point
zero two five or something and then min
and max is going to be zero and one
uh and then we'll also have our fade
which i will probably make really slow
uh and then we'll make it again i guess
zero and one like i'm not really sure
what this should be the default value is
like point zero five point zero zero
five i think um and yeah this will be
the fade so if we if we jump into the
circle render component let's just make
sure we have everything yeah radius is
important so radius the thing with
radius though and the reason why i don't
even know if we necessarily need this is
that we should be able to take that from
the scale so a scale of one means a
diameter of one so i think i want to cut
radius i don't i don't see why we would
have that
uh again you know there are uses for it
maybe you want to have like a circle
renderer and a sprite render component
at the same time and you want like a
different size for the circle for
whatever reason then i don't know there
are maybe some use cases but
almost all of them usually end with just
make a separate child entity
or sibling entity
and give that the circle render
component then it has its own transform
component and you can do whatever you
want with it so that's why we're going
to keep it simple and we're going to get
rid of the radius
thickness of course is like the outline
thickness i don't know if that's worth
specifying but whatever um okay so we
now have a way to control the parameters
of the circle but we have no way to add
it as a component so let's go ahead and
do that so we should have like some add
component um pop up here which is what
we use like for sprite renderer
components so we'll obviously duplicate
this with the circle renderer component
and we're pretty much done so this is
cool now because we have the ability to
add this component to any entity now in
the ui and we can also modify the
parameters that's really all we need to
get started we also need to worry about
serialization and duplicating entities
and all that stuff but we'll do that
stuff at the end
so rendering wise how is this going to
work well we know that we have to run a
custom shader and we also know that
uh more or less the the geometry is
going to be the same so the fact that
the geometry is the same tells me
immediately that we can reuse the index
buffer because we're literally just
drawing quads
well and we can also use these quad
vertex positions to actually set up the
geometry that we need in the correct
location and we can match it together
now we can't batch it together with our
existing geometry because we're going to
use a different shader obviously it's
going to be our circle shader so that is
important to know
also the vertex buffer is going to be
entirely different why because stuff
like text quad text index tiling factor
none of this stuff is relevant and
furthermore we need a way to set
thickness and fade
so what does that mean that means that
we need to make a new type of vertex and
this is going to be called our circle
vertex this is going to live in a
special circle vertex buffer so we have
a position we have color now um the rest
of these are basically going to be
uh let's see so we're going to have our
um
thickness that's it i was trying to
remember what that other parameter was
and fade now you could batch these into
like you know some vector called params
and then that's just kind of like you
know excess thickness
wise fade i don't know if there's really
any
benefit to doing that um there would be
if there were like some alignment issues
with this and there was like excessive
padding like if it was 16 by padded or
whatever and floats were 16-bit aligned
that could be more efficient
i think that again you know hazel 2d
game engine series we'll keep it simple
we'll keep it like this
uh we'll keep them as two separate
variables and i think that should be
okay if anyone wants to correct me and
be like no like it's definitely going to
be more efficient to have it as a vector
sure let me know in the comments below
we can talk about it but otherwise i'm
going to do this for now okay looks good
to me
i guess if you wanted to be really cool
as well you could kind of do something
like this
where your um
maybe i will do this
just because uh
if you know this would make this would
make sense packing it like this but
again um for now i'm gonna leave it like
this because i can't tell you off the
top of my head what exactly is gonna
happen with this
okay so let's go ahead and make it um
inside uh here so we have um quad vertex
buffer now it's probably worth
correcting this texture shader to be
called something else just because like
it doesn't make much sense being called
texture shader this is our quad shader
really uh so we will probably change
that later but let's go ahead and copy
these three
and we're going to call it circle vertex
array
because we're going to have a different
vertex array for it we need to it's
going to have a different vertex buffer
layout and a circle vertex buffer and a
circle shader so these three things
let's go ahead and make them we'll jump
to where we make this stuff
uh and we make quad vertex okay yeah so
the quad vertex buffer base and quad
index count we're gonna have to
duplicate this and have a circle index
count this is pretty easy with an
existing batch render again you really
just need to duplicate a lot of these
things for to be circles instead of
quads find replace quad circle that kind
of stuff
but if we jump into here
this is the next step i want to um
copy this uh and
let's come down here where we have some
space maybe before the white texture
circles and i'll set up the circle stuff
so again this is very much
just find replace um
trying to get this stuff to be a circle
instead of that we can probably reuse
these max vertices do we need to also
have 20 000 circles
probably not um realistically it's
probably a better strategy to implement
some kind of resizing vertex buffer kind
of like the way that like an scd vector
would work
the reason being that you know this is
gonna depend on what game you're making
maybe your game is all about circles so
first of all why do i have twenty
thousand chords that i don't need or
vice versa my game doesn't use a single
circle and yet i have 20 000
a vertex buffer with enough memory for
20 000 quads sitting around for no
reason so i do recognize this stuff is
not ideal uh but again this might be
something we can do in optimization
october next year or something like that
um because i don't want to get bogged
down with optimization stuff at the
moment but yes if you're implementing
this in your engine maybe you'd want to
make it resizable start off with like
100 or something more reasonable and
then just have it resize from there
using some kind of result like plus 50
percent like an std vector would do or
like doubling every time whatever you
want
okay
um so uh s data vertex buffer is that
really a thing no it's quad vertex
buffer so circle vertex buffer circle
fedex array circle everything
basically now here's the cool part
though um this index buffer that we have
here we can actually set the same quad
index buffer to also be used for our
circle vertex array because again there
it is identical geometry we don't need
to make another one of these we can just
reference that same existing index
buffer since the indices are the same
um
use
a quad ib i'm just going to add a little
comment here just so that it's clear
that this is intentional not like some
copy paste error
so uh i'm just what i like to do at the
end of this by the way is if you just go
ctrl f within this it'll show you the
selection it's hard to see here because
i'm in the way my face but that's okay
if you just type in like the word quad
into here uh we want to make sure that
it doesn't show up where it shouldn't
because if it does then we've probably
just forgotten to replace it somewhere
so you can see quad is nowhere to be
found obviously quad ib is fine but
otherwise you know we've we've
successfully replaced it with circle
everywhere so that's kind of just what
i'm checking for okay so position color
and then the rest
we can take from here from the rest of
our parameters so we have a thickness
these names are absolutely useless by
the way they're just for us really as
strings i don't even know like we do
this like in directx and hlsl you do
need to kind of have these attribute
names um but
this is just we could have just made
something that didn't have names and
just had a layout uh but i don't know i
guess i think we're sticking to this for
now so we'll have um
these these are both floats and uh i
think that's pretty much it let's just
curl some of this white space
um and yeah we're good okay so there we
go position color thickness and fade and
the entity id so that will make our
circles obviously clickable so that we
can just click on them to select which
is important as well
okay um are we done with this part i
think we are so how do we how do we
actually draw these well again this is
going to be quite simple um let's grab
so how do we want to draw these so
probably just by using a transform again
position size useful but realistically
this is how we're going to draw them
like 99 of the time
so um we'll do draw circle
i know it's more like a filled in circle
thing but doesn't matter because the
circles can be both filled in and not
filled in so it's okay
um so transform transform color and then
we need the rest of our parameters so we
we need thickness which can have a
default value of one if we want and we
can have a um
our fade as a default value 0.05
again they will realistically all be set
the reason why i'm setting defaults here
is because if we call this as part of
like some c plus code because we're
debugging something maybe we can emit
some of the parameters if we need to
okay so what is this going to do well
let's refer to draw quad because it's
really going to do the same thing the
draw quad that has a color though
so uh let's
let's just start by copying the entire
function because that's kind of what
we'll be doing
okay so we have a quad vertex account
which we use to iterate through here i
think someone like this code was like a
pull request or someone pulled in i
don't think i would necessarily
necessarily write it like this uh
but it's okay that it's like this um
so quad index count max yeah so this
whole next batch situation i don't even
know where we sit on that so if we kind
of get
if we
because the thing is this
this flush function at the moment like
it flushes just quads in the fu like the
way that i'm going to write this right
now it's going to flush both circles and
quartz but
they are separate so it makes sense to
have a flush quads
that's a separate function it will just
present the quads
and then that way you can start writing
more quads if you exceed that 20 000
limit right
i i did mention a resizable vertex
buffer before but obviously you don't
need to bash them into one draw call you
can have a hundred thousand quads and
that will be five draw calls and that's
totally fine right so you don't need to
implement the whole recyclable thing but
maybe it would be more optimal obviously
and if you start off with like 100 quads
and then turns out your game's rendering
tens of thousands that you just actually
do resize your batches
uh dynamically so that's kind of what i
was talking about but yeah of course you
could just flush keep flushing keep
drawing and then you'll have a bunch of
draw calls per frame
okay it's a draw circle so basically
what i'm saying is to do
implement for circles we're probably not
going to do this today
um not that it's particularly difficult
this can be an exercise for the reader
actually or the viewer if you guys want
to do this and submit it as a pull
request feel free it's very simple to do
um i'm just conscious of the fact that
this video is already like half an hour
long uh but you just need to make like a
flush quartz flush circles and then
obviously next batch you wouldn't just
arbitrarily have next batch uh you would
have like
like separated functions to reset all of
these things or at the end of the scene
you know you'd flush everything and at
the beginning of the scene you would
reset everything like this is doing so
that's all you're just separating them
so that if you need to you can you can
um actually call you know reset and
flush on a specific type of geometry
that render it is rendering and by
geometry i mean like primitive type i
guess because we're also going to add
lines later and that will be its own
thing as well
okay so everything has four vertices i
don't really see the need for that
constant um
so uh
quarter vertex buffer pointer it becomes
obviously circle vertex buffer pointer
position color stays the same
um and then uh yeah and we obviously
reuse quad vertex positions but oh we
actually need one more thing um sorry i
kind of forgot see this is what i mean
by implementing this stuff from a shader
from memory uh we actually do need a few
more attributes because we need to know
the local space now um we don't have a
uv coordinate this has a uv right
because that's just what shader toy
provides it's just one of the shader
inputs is this kind of um
frag quad thing which actually it's
right here right but we don't have that
we could use like
gl frag chord or whatever i don't really
want to do that because obviously we're
not filling the screen either so what we
need to do is basically have a value
that is from negative one to one like
this
so that we can actually run it through
this this equation basically in this
algorithm so um the way that we're going
to do that is we're going to add
something else called local position now
do we still need normal position well
yes because this is this becomes like
our world position and obviously this is
in world space with the transform matrix
already applied it's very different than
the other thing right whereas this is
like our local position i don't know why
i decided to make that a
um
a float but it's a vec3 right so this
local position
because i just thought zero to one but
it has to be obviously nature in each
axis and they're probably not i probably
could just have it be like a vector ii
instead but
um we'll keep it as a vector here so
level position maybe we can make some
cool 3d sphere circles later so local
position is just going to be one of four
values basically
um and it's going to basically fall into
being the quad vertex position
because if you look at this we can just
approximate it from here so this gives
us a value of negative 0.5 to 0.5 we
want to be negative 1 to 1 so i'm just
going to multiply this by 2.
that's it
basically what that will end up being is
just negative 1 negative 1 on the bottom
left then
positive 1 negative 1 on the bottom
right positive 1 1 positive 1 positive 1
on the top right and then negative 1
positive 1 on the top left that's what
that does so thickness thickness
and then
fade fade
okay that's it um quad index count uh
becomes circle index count we want to
draw these independently obviously
that's why we have the two different
counts
and then um
[Music]
yeah so this is a stat thing uh we can
leave quad count because that will these
are really quads that we're rendering
again if you i guess you could separate
this up and whatever
too many too many choices is a game
engine do whatever you want
um okay that's probably looking good now
obviously we just modified this so we
should definitely make sure that we
modify
this
now if these are vec3s though
uh we're just these are vect4s right
yeah these are vectors this is a vector3
so there should be an implicit
conversion here into a vector3 because
that's a vector
okay
i don't know maybe maybe it is worth
making this like a
uh
a float two instead
difficult difficult choices i just don't
see the need for the z component at all
but we'll see okay so um let's move on
so what's the next step well we need to
make sure that we
integrate this with like start batch and
stuff so start batch uh basically just
resets our variables
which need to do the same thing for
circles
so circle index count and the circle
vertex buffer pointer needs to be reset
and in flush we simply need to draw this
now quad index count return that's not
really how this works anymore uh more so
if quad index count we need to draw this
so we do this
um and then if we have a circle index
count so if that's not zero because it
gets reset to zero at the beginning of
the batch then we draw the circles so
how do we do that well we need to first
set the circle and you can you guys can
see this is literally like just copying
and pasting everything
um but it's obviously a different set of
data here because these are going to be
filled with completely different
completely different bytes of data
um not just because they're circles and
not like not not just because it's like
a different instance of the vedic buffer
but the layout is different and
everything
so
circle circle circle is the gist of that
no textures to bind um but we do have to
bind this and we do have to increase the
draw calls so texture shader is now
going to be circle shader so let's go
ahead and go to where the texture shader
gets loaded duplicate this circle shader
and i'm going to call this renderer 2d
underscore circle okay we're going to
rename this to render a 2d underscore
quad or something a bit later but um but
this circle shader
uh is what we're going to bind here
obviously we haven't made the shadow yet
we're about to write that
and then we do draw index with the
circle a vertex array and the circle
index count
and i believe that is it
i believe that is all we need to do
um i don't think there's anything else
that needs to be done really so it's
pretty simple that's how we integrate
that now let's write the shader so over
here in shaders uh i'm just going to
open up this actual file explorer thing
uh let's copy and paste texture and
we'll call it render a 2d underscore
circle since we're here we might as well
rename this to render a 2d underscore
quad
and then i'll obviously rename the
texture shader so let's rename this
texture shader to quad shader
uh and then we will also rename the file
that we're trying to load
to be
this
okay so we've got our quad shader we've
got our circle shader
uh hopefully that will work um it should
clear the cache and recompile like well
the
this will be it'll be gone from the
cache because we've changed the name so
it's okay
and um let's go ahead and refresh this
shaders list and look at render tv
circles so i copied this so this is our
renderer 2d
circle shader
hazel 2d
renderer hazel 2d will be cool with our
little
branding or whatever you want to call it
how cool am i
i think it needs some of this
there you go
pretty cool
um okay i don't like the way that looks
at all maybe i'll change that but anyway
so so
now that's done all right um let's copy
that kind of layout that we had so we
had a world position we had local
position and then we had color and then
we had uh
two floats so thickness
and fade
and then we had the entity id let's
change these attributes one two three
four five
and uh we'll still have the camera
because we need that uh do we need that
i guess we i guess we do view projection
well the view should be like
are we
yeah no that's fine yes of course we
need the view projection sorry the
transform is a thing that's baked in
um so vertex output color text chord uh
and tiling factor changes to color
um well we need the local position in
the fragment shader
the color and then the thickness and the
fade
so
the text index so yeah we kind of need
to have uh now this
will change
i think
i never know what this is going to end
up being man so
i think this is i think every 16 bytes
is one location slot and it's probably
padded as well
so uh so how many bytes is this 12 plus
16 so 28 and then 32 36
so 36 and every 16 bytes so what does
that mean that means it takes up three
slots so this will be number three still
am i correct i don't know i know i never
know
um so let's just do this uh that's
location three and we'll see if it works
out
um
[Music]
otherwise and the reason we have to have
this here in the first place is because
it needs to be flat and we can't make it
flat in there so uh tiling effect has
also gone oh well actually no italian so
let's do the local position
then we can do the uh thickness
and then we can do the fade
okay so let's make this in the right
order as well so it's easier to
understand thickness fade okay good
and then gel position remains the same
so that's our vertex shader done
uh then the fragment shader is going to
be a bit easier to do hopefully so let
me just copy the um vertex output struct
to make sure it's the same obviously
we don't need this and this should be
number three now i think maybe
um no textures either
and now we can go to shader toy
and
um so i've got shader toy here i'm just
going to literally copy everything and
we're going to go from there so paste
and let's discuss this
so uh circle color is now an actual
thing right so we can replace circle
color with input dot color
we call it input yes input.color so
that's done thickness
also a thing now so input.thickness
and that's done
fade
fade is
uh
input dot fade
this shader is actually getting shorter
um so uv so uv is literally just like
that negative one to one thing i was
talking about so uv is just going to be
the local position
um now the aspect ratio it completely
doesn't matter actually
this is important though because um
[Music]
the local position but we're ready but
we're changing the quad so yeah no this
is fine so we don't need this either so
the thing is like what's gonna happen
here
is um
[Music]
the
like if we if we modify the transform
like the scale of the actual
entity then it that's what will stretch
out our circle otherwise we don't need
to do this aspect ratio thing because we
assume that we're rendering on a square
if we're not rendering on the square the
only way we get to that state is if we
actually play with the scale and
obviously that's a deliberate thing so
therefore that's kind of we would we
would allow it to be an ellipse because
that's what we would expect
so um that means that yeah none of this
needs to exist
so uv is just going to be input
dot
um local position now in the shader toy
code
you can see that this u this uv was in
fact a vector so that's what i was
talking about there's no reason for this
to be a vec3
um
to be honest so i probably will change
it to be a vector
okay
so i think that actually is is is it i
mean obviously we need to set like
output color i don't know why let's just
call it out oh color and what's color to
color 2 is the entity id right so entity
id uh becomes
um
a v entity id
and then color
is what this is
and that's it so really quite simple um
[Music]
yeah that's i think that's all there is
to it and that's how we render circles
so
um now we have to actually implement it
in our scene class so
the same way that we go through in the i
think it's on update right so on update
editor we go through and we draw all the
sprites if there's a sprite renderer
component let's just put this in a scope
um let's do the same thing we can't
group them because that actually like
plays with the memory layout um and
we've already decided transformers
render it together so let's call this a
circle renderer component this is going
to be a view instead so we can have our
emergency review uh i think we can just
list it out i never know what version of
ant i'm using
um because there's a few
but
uh
so we're going through all the entities
here i'm going to do view
dot get
this and that
this should be referenced they are
and
um draw sprite will do draw circle
instead and then this is where it's just
going to take in all of our parameters
so color is the first one so sprite
let's call this circle
or circle renderer so circle color
circle
thickness
and circle fade
now i guarantee to you that i probably
have made a mistake somewhere but that's
actually all we need to do so do we have
a on update run time as well this is
this must be on update runtime so we
need to do the same thing here um so
where we do the draw sprite stuff with
the group this code is actually
identical i believe so let's just copy
both of these just because i added that
scope as well and i want to keep it the
reason i have a scope is just because
it's easier to kind of separate this so
draw
sprites draw circles um by separate i
mean you know stuff like view i can
always use the variable name view
because it's in its own scope and it's
not going to leak into any other scope
so
that's just how i roll
adding in our comments and i think if we
hit f5 now
uh we might be able to actually render
some circles which will be pretty
exciting but as i mentioned i will be
shocked if i get this right from the
first try so we'll see uh this is just
our typical on component added error
message that if you guys have been
following the series you know what
appears every time i add a component
because i've forgotten about this
useless contraption that we have here
but uh we have to add this like so
and um
[Music]
yeah what do you guys think is it going
to work is it going to work is it going
to not work
um let's find out
so
apparently the shaded isn't compiled
that's okay i forgot about that so a
position
undeclared identifier
and that's basically the only problem it
looks like yeah that's because i called
it like world position or something so
let's make sure that this is
uh
called world position
take two
uh still not compiling uh location
overlapping use of location three really
i thought i
okay well it's not an overlapping use of
location here but three must be
overlapping so i guess my brilliant math
or whatever i tried to do didn't work
out let's try four
uh still not compiling uh
different error though assign convert
from four component flow to three
components so this is
line 26
um is it the fragment shader though or
the vertex shader weird that our code
doesn't say
uh that's a bit annoying isn't it
so what is sure what stage is this
thanks man
is there any way to see what stage this
is without looking at this
oh we can look at the path maybe that's
the fragment shader because it's dot
frag anyway that's terrible we should
definitely print the stage but fragment
shader line 26 problem is our lines
start from 45 45 minus 26 is like 19 i
think so that doesn't help us at all
doesn't it
45 plus 26 is what i meant so if that's
so it should be it's i think it's this
one here so input color oh because input
colors of x4 that's why well in that
case i think we can just do
because what are we doing we're doing
color and then with times equals just
for the rgb so this is just let me just
do color times input color
um and that's kind of it
i think that should be okay
but yeah those error messages definitely
need some work
uh still bad
um
oh yeah sorry so this color is of it yep
so let's do
that
um yeah vec4 times that i feel like
let's just set the color to maybe be the
input color
and then we can multiply the rgb by
color because that's a vec3 that might
be that might look a little cleaner i
don't know this is obviously just up to
however you want it to look like we'll
just do it that way sure
shouldn't have any more errors anymore
so what can we do well let's go let's
open our physics scene for fun
um now we don't see anything though
where is our where is everything now
we're not rendering anything so that's
how good i am
apparently i broke just rendering in
general so
let's figure out what's going on there
what how did i manage to do that
so i'll take you guys through the
debugging i have to sit through this
because i do as well so so draw spry
let's just make sure that's still
happening
and i mean i don't really know
right well we have a different shader
right but
we're definitely still trying to render
sprites and we obviously should be
rendering them the same way
um that hasn't changed so flush
should uh try it so it is trying to draw
stuff
and it's doing chord shader bind
let's render 2d quad
and then draw indexed and that seems to
be drawing but we don't see anything on
the screen
so
and we're not drawing any circles yet i
believe no we're not
so why
why
why is it suddenly not drawing anything
so the only thing i can really think of
is um the fact that
i guess we we try to steal the index
buffer from here but surely it's not
that we should be able to share index
buffers right
oh
okay
oh i know what this is i remember this
problem
ah yes
i remember this problem because this
happened during the live stream like a
month or more ago when i implemented
this we have quite a fatal flaw in our
actual render commands because
when we
uh do flush and so here we are trying to
draw a bunch of quads
guess what we totally don't do we
totally don't actually bind this vertex
array so we say we want draw index with
this vertex array but you can see here
nothing is binding the vertex array
so if we look back i mean we're binding
the shader and that's great but we
obviously shouldn't be expected to bind
the vertex array outside of this
function especially if we're passing it
in
so if we go back here let's just do
um a gl and i don't know why we suddenly
decided to unbind the texture as well
that i feel like that shouldn't be there
that's a bit weird um but gl bind vertex
array and we can do vertex i mean vertex
ray might have a bind function
but i like to uh
well apparently we don't have a get
render id
i was going to say i was trying to
actually put all the open gel code into
here but that's okay so we'll bind the
vertex array then we'll get the count
and use it here and yeah that weird
texture on binding thing i don't think
we should necessarily be doing that
um
but anyway so scenes and then physics 2d
so now we see this
and now we should uh go back to
um
uh what did i disable i disabled so yeah
the uh
the index buffer
we'll put that back so now let's see if
we can render circles yeah see that's
the benefit of doing these live streams
as well the fact that um
the fact that we encounter some of these
issues on stream and it's a bit more of
a easier place to debug it than when i'm
making a video okay so
let's try so how do we render a circle
well let's add an empty entity here it
is
and let's add a circle renderer
component and that should be it and you
can see we see a circle now there's
looks like there's like
definitely some issues with alpha
it's not blending properly at all
now i think we
actually set the alpha to be one though
um so let's go back to render a 2d
circle so color
color is input color
which
i mean has an alpha of
up that's fine but then the outsides
okay so the outsides here so this is a
color oh yes of course so this is one of
the things i talked about in the actual
in the actual circles video where i did
the
the
whatever it's called the um
[Music]
the shader toy example so on shader toy
we were playing with color because we
were making an opaque thing right but in
in reality what we kind of want to do
here is we don't want to play with color
we want to just have a kind of an alpha
value so this should be our kind of
circle
circle alpha or something
and it should just be a float it doesn't
need to be a vec3 because we're not we
don't care about a color so the only way
we made it at 3 is we just duplicate it
across all the channels the data that's
it so this just becomes circle alpha
output color.rgb can be this dot rgb if
we want and you'll see why i'm
separating it in a minute but then the
alpha right oh actually let's do
let's do this let's do uh output color
equals input color
and then we'll do output color
um dot a times equals circle alpha
the reason being this way um if we have
a lower alpha
as a as the color it will also apply to
this it'll make the whole circle be
partially transparent uh but that that's
that's it so i don't know if circle
alpha is the best
thing here
maybe just circle
circle circle circle
um
now we have to recompile the shader by
clearing the cache so let's open up the
cache folder i this is very annoying i
know i will fix this
by having like a
shader registry or something where we
can just store like a hash of the shader
and then recompile it if stuff changes
um i like that approach uh okay so let's
create our circle again
move it over here
and then let's um
see it work perfectly because that's how
i roll so
um there you go there's your perfect
circle uh you can play with the color
and you can see it works and then we can
also um
basically go to the alpha channel and
make it partially transparent and it
works now at the moment the reason why
blending is working perfectly is because
we rendered the circles physically after
we rendered the sprites this is just
like a fluke kind of that it's working
oh and yeah selection works as well so
we can select
um
but but here's something so you can see
i can't select the square behind it
because the bounds of the circle is
actually the geometry whereas if i move
it here now i can select it so let's fix
that that's very easy to fix
we just need to make sure that um
uh we just need to make sure
that
the
entity id
is only really being output if
we're within the circle
so um
[Music]
how should we do that so i guess if
circle
is greater than zero
then we can output the entity id i guess
that would probably be a sensible way of
doing it right
um let's recompile that shader though
yeah super annoying
believe me i am as annoyed as you are if
not more
um it's a epic one hour video as usual
okay so
let's drag that in
all right let's make our circle again we
can't serialize anything yet because
that's also how we roll circle renderer
orange because that's the best color
obviously
um
and uh now let's try and click on
this
and that failed
why is it selecting that
what
i keep dragging this hang on
why is it so oh
yeah why does it select the floor
how is this the floor
oh well actually um
[Music]
okay let's do this instead
the reason is obvious i think it's it's
going to fill the buffer with data
anyway so what we should do is we should
probably discard if this is the case
so if we're outside of the bounds of the
circle let's just discard those
fragments and that way what we're
writing in is stuff that definitely
needs to actually be written in so if
it's greater than sorry if it's less
than one
um but one is also not really
see unfortunately it's gonna depend on
the fade right because you're going to
have a little bit of
because we're smooth stepping it
so
you can probably calculate this by
looking at the fade because the
less than
no but i guess to be honest
we we should only really discard if it's
exactly zero though right
because
if there's even a little bit then it's
it's being it's like part of the circle
so that would make sense so let's do
this
um let's try this but yeah that makes
sense it's because the the data there is
probably garbage um because it is still
gonna write something
uh it will just be whatever it
yeah i think
um so let's go empty entity
and
adding a circle renderer um i'll just
differentiate the color
so it's easier to see but
let's see if we can
select this now
okay and we can
okay now what we should be able to do
and what we should have tested is like
the thickness so you can see that also
works so now to be really cool we should
also be able to select this as you can
see through the circle so that's the
circle over here and then if we click
here we select the thing behind it right
so that should still work again we're
doing this on a pixel level um that's
why it's so nice to do picking with
like
you know this kind of pixel buffer
because it's always going to be pixel
perfect and you get you get so much
control over it whereas try and do this
if you had raycasts it's not going to
work because the geometry is physically
there right
um so yeah so this this approach is
quite good and i quite like it
for this kind of stuff okay um so we've
confirmed that works let's play with the
fade
yeah that obviously works as well so see
this is what i mean like if we now click
on this part it's still the circle right
but if we click here that's already not
part of the circle because we made it
equal zero so i think that's probably a
good move
um
yeah there we go
so we can have quite blurry circles um
and yeah we also should be able to make
them as thin as we want by just making
well let's let's go back to like having
point zero zero five or whatever and
let's make this like point one or point
zero one and you can see this is kind of
what like a normal thin circle that we
might use for visualizing like circle
colliders uh would look like and we
should still be able to select it yeah
kind of hard but we can still click on
it select it again it's per pixel so
it's literally going to be perfect
which is great and then of course as i
mentioned you can you can stretch these
out now if you do that a lot then these
edges are going to distort right so if i
finally find this you can see how much
thicker this is that's kind of expected
because we are doing this in that local
space
uh you could probably fix that by taking
in taking a scale into account or using
like shaded derivatives like we talked
about something like that um how do i
get back to where i was
but yeah that's in general that is
hopefully uh helpful to you guys as to
how you can implement my circles video
into a game engine uh let's hit play um
do we see the circle during uh playing
now we should
it's hard to see where the circle
actually is no actually we should have
seen it then i think let's make it a bit
thicker
huh we don't see it do we
why is it not being rendered during
play mode
that's interesting so if we go back to
scene because i'm pretty sure i added it
there
so this is update editor this is update
run time so this is where we actually do
it if main camera then we should be
drawing it
um
this is all in the begin scene thing so
it should still oh
yes okay so when we do begin saying
we need to make sure that we
oh no it's just a uniform buffer right
sorry i thought that maybe it needed
like a per
per um
a per
shader buffer thing but that's not how
it works and also obviously it works
with the editor camera so
very suspicious
why this isn't being rendered
in
oh no it's not suspicious at all it's
because i'm not the entity doesn't
physically exist in the runtime because
i'm not copying it so duplicate entity
let's quickly add in
um circle render component and then if
we look at like another place maybe
where we're doing this or when we do run
time when we do the actual scene copying
which is
uh
copy
then we need to make sure that we copy
the circle renderer component as well
now we're going to change the system to
just iterate through like a list i think
or something like that in the future
of components and then that way we can
not do this manually because of course
it's very error prone every time you add
a component you have to add it to like
500 different places which is really
annoying
but
that's how it is for now so now we have
our circle
our beautiful
orange circle which i will replicate
perfectly
um and then if we hit play you can see
it here as well okay brilliant so that
is basically circles now there's a few
things that we have to fill in fill in
the gaps of such as the serialization of
circles right we want to be able to
actually serialize the data again super
simple i don't know if it's even worth
me doing this on stream or like on
video but i i guess i will probably do
it at the beginning of the next episode
um actually let's just do it now like
who wants to watch that right you guys
can probably just end the video here if
you want after you leave a like um but
basically to serialize it we just have
to go to the serializer let's look at
how we did the sprite renderer component
let's copy the sprite renderer component
let's call this circle renderer
component
i'll do this little speeder on this
because it it's pretty easy
so circle render component color
thickness
and
fade are those the only three things i
think they might be how's my speed
running going pretty badly
thickness and
fade circle render component yep okay um
whoops that's it uh that looks good and
then we do the same thing for the
deserialization
which is here
circle renderer component
[Music]
so there's our so we'll call the circle
render component crc color
thickness and fade
so thickness is a float
and so is fade
and that i think is it so add this are
these parentheses
let's go back to here i just want to
make sure yeah call things okay cool
so let's try and now just save a scene
basically and make sure that works so
scenes physics 2d
we'll add a circle we'll call it circle
add circle
circle renderer
don't have circle colliders yet
soon um thickness let's make that like
point one
we want we won't make it too thin
and then i'll just put it like here or
something
brilliant
let's save this now do we have control s
no wait we need to add a control s
so assets scenes and physics 2d yes
replace get rid of this well we don't
have to we could have just dragged it in
but i guess this is more proof and it
works okay civilization is done thank
you guys for watching the video if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to hit
the like button below and also help
support the series by going to
patreon.com
where you will be helping to support
this series as i've mentioned but also
you'll get access to the big hazel which
i also showed earlier in this video
you'll be able to play around with all
that stuff in 3d and uh yeah it just
lets us keep making these videos so huge
thank you to all of your support thank
you for sticking with this one hour
video next time um i'm not 100 sure what
we'll we'll probably just move on to
like line rendering or something next
time we're kind of doing this rendering
thing so we might as well kind of finish
that but after that it's going to be
like circle colliders and more kind of
box dirty physics things thank you guys
for watching i'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you